hello rejects this is Greg this is young
we're launching a new segment here
called a weekend of horror for the month
of October John is the social media
manager at bloom house they if they're
responsible for a lot of big horror
movies such as the insidious film was
the Paranormal Activity films I urge you
some films are not horror movie like
whiplash and have a new western coming
out and evaluate violence yeah so they
do they do a variety of films primarily
horror films john is a big horror
enthusiast I really grew up on horror I
used to there's a channel I don't even
know if it exists anymore that I grew up
watching called the monster channel
where is twenty-four hours twenty-four
hours a day just non-stop horror movies
and I was watching that when I was like
11 years old about movies cuz I think
you had the monster channel I don't
think we had the monster channel so I
was married yeah it was a rare channel I
think a lot of people had it but we
wanted to launch this segment so we're
gonna start off with what we would like
to see in horror movies yeah John
actually had he came up with this topic
and so I'd like him to kick it off John
to you let's establish what we love
about horror like what our tastes are
and then we can that can kind of justify
Oh like the should have prepared more
let's do this it's already this stuff
that scares me the most in horror movies
is always anything that feels real or
like you know human cruelty really
freaks me out but there's a lot of
different kinds of horror that I really
do like for me it's very simple for what
I like to see in horror movies anyone
can say it's for any genre I'll of good
character at any horror film um
especially because I feel like it's a
little bit harder to do in a horror
movie because most people when they do
horror films I feel like they get so
caught up in the thrill the suspends the
horror itself and that content if you
look at any of the greatest horror films
and any kind of horror genre anywhere
from like movies like alien to poultry
guys like two very different kinds of
horror movies they'll come back to the
same reason for why they're so scary
it's because we really are invested in
the people in those
movies yeah its people you can connect
to in a terrible situation and and the
more you can connect to the character
the more you can think about how you
would be out in a situation like that
cuz horror is tough for that reasons
like a lot of people are attracted to
the style and like the cool [ __ ] and the
scares and stuff like that and those
things are important to like a good
character driven horror is unlike a gang
out and what I mean by good character
too is I mean personality within the
characters as well I love it when
characters and films have a sense of
humor whether it be a drama or horror
film things that are not categorized as
comedies yet every once in a while the
characters will make you laugh because
they're just in real life a lot of
people just have a sense of humor
because humor is the thing that we all
have yeah so I like to see I like to see
movies with characters that have really
defined personalities really human
personalities even like the devil's
rejects no one's likable and but they
all have personality there's some how
likable in a weird way because of their
their humor their appeal their their
rawness about it one that the devil's
rejects takes unlike ability and makes
it fascinating by basically setting up
good guys and bad guys theoretically and
then flipping those dynamics around yeah
so it's like yeah none of these people
are likeable except I feel differently
about them all now and that's kind of
engaging growing up I was always super
into just just Halloween in general and
the macabre there's a fantasy element I
really enjoy you know horror is the
place like war movies of the place where
you can get together and sort of agree
that we're all gonna address a fear of
some kind in a safe environment you know
and maybe have a little bit in the
process I don't even just like the fun
stuff every now and again I've got a
taste for you know like an ugly horror
movie that's the thing that I appreciate
sometimes because there is ugliness in
life and I think ugly art is also valid
that's one of the few places you can
really explore that is through a horror
movie and stuff like that all right
enough set up John what he would you
like to see no horror movie I want to
see more weird stuff that's what I
always kind of come back to is like an
umbrella is like I really like it when
films have the guts to get weird and
when people allow that to happen cuz
that's the stuff that's truly unsettling
getting surreal I mean like it's easy to
point like David Lynch and stuff like
that I like the of the recent string of
like psychological trauma as represented
by a monster sort of move
like the babadook or goodnight mommy was
we're sort of like that nothing I
necessarily love goodnight mommy but but
it has a lot of that like it's very
strange and very weird and it takes you
up garden it makes you feel funny about
your body and stuff I'd like to see more
body horror to body [ __ ] is a is a very
potent genre that you don't see a whole
lot of my response to this would be a
little different it's not so much about
wanting to see what I would want to see
in horror movies boom how I want to see
horror infused in more kinds of movies
you know like we watch shows nowadays
that are like like I'm good Marvel show
or like preacher the action and
adventure is kind of secondary even
though in a film it would kind of be
primary for a lot of people that's
actually secondary and it would be cool
to see like a big budget like even a
superhero movie that decided to make it
a little scary not advertise it as a
horror film but include those horror
elements because I think horror is one
of the most engaging emotions in a film
it's one of the things that can pull you
in the most especially me catches you by
surprise like jaws for example you
wouldn't really categorize that as a
horror film to a lot of people but it
really is a strong horror film but it's
kind of a horror film in disguise and I
would like to see horror kind of be a
disguise through a lot more films too
like I yesterday was talking to a writer
who writes a lot of romantic comedies
you brought this up a lot like you don't
really see strong romance in a
whorehouse you you kind of get like
let's set up this guy oh ok these two
love each other that way one of them
dies it'll be [ __ ] depressing yeah
like we care that this guy cuz he's got
this other thing that he worries about
so high character development yeah I
would love to see more like actual
horror romance or like gothic romance I
know a lot of people weren't super
receptive to crimson peak stuff like
that I kind of Miss like I was watching
I was like I kind of Miss what this is
like a real Gothic romance you know and
I think there is horror to be found in
love that's more than just ah the person
I love is being attacked by ghosts I'd
love to see the interplay of genres I'd
love to see like a true bone tomahawk
was something I love lately it was like
a horror Western yeah it was awesome I
would like to see action or actually get
done well like I feel like the first one
that comes to mind me that's actually
done well as aliens the James Cameron's
movie that's an action movie sci-fi and
[ __ ] scary a lot of the time it's
terrifying and i love that that film
managed to do all those things I feel
like when you get a movie that's like a
horror element but they make it an
action element as well it usually just
becomes some action film I think of
films like Q Jackman and Van Helsing or
aaron eckhart and i frankenstein these
acts are not horrible they're not form
have like horror wallpaper yeah yeah
they're not tense the same way a horror
movie is tense there tends to the way in
action movies 10 yeah exactly exactly so
I love seeing it when horror is infused
with another genre because sometimes
when it's just horror I feel sometimes
it takes us up a little too it's very
self serious and like I've seen a lot of
horror movie trailers this year and I
haven't even posted on the channel the
reviews and I'm just like this gasps no
reaction I mean it's just kind of dull
and I don't care posted the horror
movies that were good this year is a
good year for horror in 2016 so far you
know we got lights out we got the
conjuring 2 don't wait don't breathe
these films know how to have fun with
their audiences and I would like to see
them produce more of that two films and
know how to have fun whether the crowds
at the same time though you do get your
films like the witch that kind of remind
me of like the Kubrick days that are
really about dread that kind of tone and
style where is the camera lingers for a
long time you don't know what's gonna
pop in a frame even [ __ ] like that or
it's like you're just kind of consumed
in this uncomfortable feeling you know
horror movies with an aura yeah there is
a definite horror to just dread to
feeling prolonged dread and movies like
The which are great at that or the
invitation yet another great when I saw
this year I would also like to see more
horror films I kind of parking back to
you know films like they have them
wonder to it kind of like poltergeist I
feel like you don't know the Toro was
bringing that back for a while with
films like pans labyrinth and when he
produced the orphanage but I don't feel
like don't even tries to make films like
that yeah there's a there's a sense of
wonder as well as this is [ __ ]
terrifying thing is well there's there's
got to be a better word for it but I do
miss kid horror because there's like one
that comes
everyone's yeah while you know that is
still you know kind of an actually
creepy horror movie but the kids could
get into and the only one I could think
of like really recently was ParaNorman
was when I loved that was stranger
things kind of qualifies it's a little
scary I wouldn't want a kid to watch
strange things that I wouldn't be like
halo give me oh that's what you mean by
like a like actual like kids being able
to go and watch a skill that goose bumps
yeah goose bumps is another good example
that I think and goose bumps has that
benefit of we love to mine property now
they reached over to that and they did
it justice I thought more original stuff
like that where it's not necessarily
blood and guts but it is creepy but
creepy for you know youth as well I grew
up with some stuff like that that was
you know for me and I think that's a
valid thing to do that we don't really
do much anymore is like horror for young
people and i would like to also see
horror movies with different kinds of
leads in there usually get single mom
who's really attractive still or you get
you know sad white young teens 10
Cloverfield Lane was an interesting kind
of horror film to me that's one thing
where you're like I don't know if i call
it horror fun but if you watch it you're
like you i pretty much a horror film
actually it's scary it's scary in a lot
of ways it's dready and paranoid and
cluster and while it's led by mary
elizabeth winstead you know it's like
John Goodman's also on the front of it
but I think I'd be like cool to see a
horror movie word it's like stars guy
like John Goodman and he's the
protagonist in it yeah they were it's
more challenging on the marketing side
of who the actor is in it we constantly
here in Hollywood about how scripts are
all the same they always write the same
kind of like leads and stuff it's all
about the marketing and [ __ ] and I feel
like [ __ ] the one genre that is able
to step outside the boundaries and break
the lines and try different things and I
feel like that's the one genre that
could really experiment with getting
different kinds of lead roles in there
yeah well and there's a lot of you know
like horror is one of those genres it's
a great place to explore allegoria you
know you make stories that that harken
to relevant issues or things like that
so yeah like I would love to see casting
get more diverse in a broad range of
Specter like see you know maybe
mainstream or or more mainstream
or led by other people of different
ethnicities or just different set like
it i got like John Goodman you don't
think of as a leading man yeah you know
like get a guy like that and yeah put a
story around somebody like that yeah I
would like to see some more out of the
box there are a lot of haunted house
movies come out with good performances
of those leads but it's like yeah I've
seen the family a million times I've
seen the single mother or those the
teens a million times let's see some new
different kind of characters yeah like
really different different continent
more than just different kind of
professions these characters have but
really different kind of people because
I feel like we keep seeing the same kind
of art types the same kind of people as
leads in most of these films well yeah
that's what we'd like to see in horror
movies what would you rejects like to
see you in horror movies put your
comments below talk about it argue with
each other troll whatever it takes to
get this video more popular whoo that's
how YouTube Morgan scheduled to work if
you're new to this channel subscribe and
become a regex John like we said earlier
social media manager of bloom house and
he is also the facebook.com slash real
reject social manager so go like that
page there and I want to give a shout
out again to ET see I saw what these
guys look like and I watched a little
bit other video mm-hmm I just don't
think they belong in from the camera
don't like the way they look I kind of
annoy me act like I know Allah but they
don't go to hell